we are we're here screaming did it blow
your mind when you first saw these these
bombers yeah that that stuff stuff
formularies yeah
yes something to the hole I have to say
it really it kind of takes your breath
away when you're walking past them and
you're looking up and you're like wow
well also as to what they can do
yeah yeah could you look at it now and
you're like yeah that's in present then
you think that thing can spiral and yeah
I mean they are pretty spectacular I'm
scared half to death but they're pretty
spectacular I think I would jump in so
there's a lot of things I loved about
this movie but the first thing is the
fact that Captain Marvel is arguably the
most powerful important person in the
Marvel Universe right so I love that
brie Larson is that girl
what makes brie Larson so perfect to be
the most powerful person in the Marvel
Universe brie is well not only is she a
wonderful actress that she you know in
her work outside of acting she she leads
by example she yes and she she stands up
for people who have don't have as much
voice yeah I think she's a perfect
person to play this role and you know
she I was part of the reason why I
signed up I was so excited to work with
her I've been a fan of hers for years
and and now it's it's been great it's
been great spending time with her and I
think she's a she's brilliant as a woman
watching this movie
I have to say I felt a little bit like a
badass little empowered seeing you see
Tina Shauna Annette all of you guys
really doing these amazing things in the
movie I wonder what makes you feel
empowered not in a movie but just in
life what makes you feel empowered it it
really encourages me when I see acts of
kindness I think you know there's
there's so much division in the world at
the moment lots of terrible things
happening but then when you hear or when
you see something and you see someone
acting selflessly that to me it gives
you renewed hope renewed faith in kind
of the human race and yeah that makes me
feel good it gives me it gives me
optimism and yeah it kind of gets it
kind of you know stops are you kind of
spiraling into kind of cynicism actually
it's so easy to go there and I think it
can be kind of easier to kind of think
like that and actually it's the harder
thing to stay hopeful to stay optimistic
when I hope this hope this bill makes
people feel empowered
I hope seeing women in all these
different roles in the film and a whole
spectrum of different kind of female
relationships in this film whether it's
the mother-daughter friendships
rivalries you kind of see the whole the
whole spectrum I think that's great I
don't think you've really seen that and
a film like this before dude what about
you it makes you feel it's hard to talk
that really I think I'm thinking what
she just said what Gemma just said is is
is a thing of real beauty and you know
kindness understanding humility I think
also you know seeing people finding joy
in life with with with with very little
yeah
one of the things that worries me most
about about the world I live in in in
the West is that we've we seem to be
caught up with leads to the answer is by
bringing something into your life rather
than looking at what you have so I think
people or communities that I've seen in
very simple or very desperate situations
who is still finding hope and
inspiration and kindness just as Gemma
just described is really moving and
makes you realise that you yourself can
get through anything because you're
probably more fortunate than most how
many cool points you got as a pop of
being in a Marvel film now are you like
top of the charts they are yeah they're
very excited my youngest son has
actually seen he saw it with me
first of all you know it's not what they
say to me it's what they say to their
friends right because with Mila still
like you know years all right yeah it's
pretty good they keep they probably I
hope keep the gushing for their mates
and pals that they go and see it with
they're just you know what's exciting is
these are experiences that I've taken
them you know we'll stock up on popcorn
and sweets and all the good bad stuff
and go and see these films together so
but curiously you know the idea of them
now seeing me in there well I hope I
don't burst the bubble I hope they're
not only like I mean there was a window
when when they were little they come and
visit me on set all the time and spend a
lot of time with me and then there was
the natural window where they were like
okay so that's really boring I don't
wanna come anymore and it was very
interesting the number of calls I got
when I was on this set many of them will
they always come down all the time just
to see a little bit I don't know if you
were like me Jude when you saw Gemma in
crazy rich Asians you took my breath
away from the moment you stepped on them
I'm serious
girl crush
scene 1 frame would I mean it really
fantastic experience how easy honest
Chairman's pretty excuse me pretty
fantastic in in everything right
that's my London London just dropping
[Laughter]
talk to everyone on that cast about how
and it kind of changed the trajectory of
their career I haven't gotten the chance
to ask you that same thing how that
experience has changed the trajectory of
even you know how you look at this
industry even in not only kind of lots
of people want to see it and it's been
entertaining but it's special because it
has it has changed in some way the
conversation or the landscape and I you
know I think it's a real privilege to be
part of a project like that and
hopefully like like this one as well
which you know in terms of
representation it's it's pushing the
conversation forwards and yeah I just
feel really grateful really really proud
really happy to have been lucky enough
to be part of these well Astrid has lots
of stories to tell so we can see you in
the sequel I hope so yeah there's tons
of amazing material in Kevin's France
trilogy so yeah what if they want to go
there there there's there's lots there
too to delve into